how're you doing today good how are you
good summertime summertime sundress
fashion I'm trying to learn up a
girlfriend is very into oh it is a
jumpsuit
once he Jinyoung she maybe not screwed
at all you recognize the floral print
though yeah yeah it's good camo
yeah good garden springtime camo so word
on the street among the viewers is that
John and Mei Lin are kind of the ones to
be so what does team Blake have to pull
out tonight to take the win hmm I can't
I can't disagree that that she's the one
to beat you know I wish it was easier
for me just you know just throw her
under the bus but it's hard she's so
good but my guys are good too and you
know I think there's there's a theory
that kind of gets floated around here
that you know if you have multiple
artists in the finale than your vote
gets all split up between your team
members and they're all gonna go to one
person on John's team you know which is
that could be true let's face it
this is my show I write the script and
the rules and who knows what could
change tonight you know but I'll get in
out may get in there with NBC or the
producers and you know change that few
rules and I'm going for the win I'm
going to win this show you never know
what could change in the writers room at
the last minute that's right that's
right
realize this show is scripted a lot of
people say it's rigged it's not rigged
it's scripted Wow
there's some incredible talent coming in
everyone from Taylor Swift to the BTS
guys have you met the BTS guys yet I
have not I haven't met them it we have
the same initials you know it's I know
and but we haven't met yet so I'm hoping
maybe they're on tomorrow night I think
I'm excited to meet them I mean my gosh
I'm yes I love it it makes me when I
went and when it comes on the radio and
I'm driving it's dangerous because I do
this with my elbows but it just makes me
do that it's a hazard but you know what
the army
the army does over there call sure
that's probably accurate now I can't let
the season rap without asking you for an
album update what is coming after God's
country which by the way nailed that
song is so amazing I think I truly love
it
Wow thank you I don't know I don't I
don't want to put out an album I really
don't I'm sure that at some point the my
record company's people are going to
pressure me into it but as of now I'm
not putting out an album this year I
know that I mean I'll be just as happy
to release just another single and and I
do I do and I've got other stuff that
I'm pumped about but when I think about
an album right now I'm just like I don't
even know that people care about them
anymore I don't know I don't know I'm
having a blast just releasing singles
maybe I'll do that from now on